- Oh, look!
You're a genius.
- I know.
- Oh my god!
- We had a lot of fun
trying on Santa stuff
and pretending to be Santas,
breaking in Ned's house,
but, the whole point of being Santa is
to bring cheer to little kids.
- Find somebody that has a want
that you can help fill, whatever it is.
- Have you two been good girls this year?
- Yes.
- What's your favorite kind of puppy?
- My little favorite
puppy is the little one.
- For my favorite
children across the world,
we have puppies that kiss the
presents before they go out.
To just give them a little
extra dose of magic.
And, I'm gonna tell you, your presents
will both have puppy kisses.
- Listen to what they say,
maybe ask them a question
about it, just interact with
them like you would anybody.
- What's your favorite dinosaur?
- Do you have little arms
like a tyrannosaurus?
You have big arms for a tyrannosaurus!
David, watch out!
David, ho ho ho!
Thank you, David.
Good eye touch!
- Violeta, I hear that
you really like science!
- Mm hmm!
It's mostly experiments
in science and art.
- What's your favorite song?
- The Titanic.
- Mrs. Clause thinks
that Leonardo DiCaprio
is very handsome.
- [Violetta] Yeah.
- But, it's a movie based
on a horrible tragedy.
- Yeah, they die.
- You just want to talk
to them like real people.
- Samia, I hear that you
like beauty and fashion.
- I do.
- What's your favorite thing?
- I guess it would go to makeup.
- What makeup would you put on me?
- Red, darkish lipstick.
- Yes girl.
- How do you get onto a nice list?
- Well, let's see, I got a million things.
- Doing chores, doing your homework,
being obedient to your parents.
- I was being a lot good.
- I clean up my room.
- We help our mom when she's sick.
- And, my sister, sometimes,
helps me with my product.
- Yes, she's also a very good girl.
- You know, there's nothing more rewarding
then giving gifts.
- What do you want for
Christmas this year?
- American Girl doll, maybe
you haven't heard of it.
Maybe you have.
- Oh, Santa knows American Girl.
Santa made American Girl doll.
- Wow!
- Yeah, I did that.
- 2-in-1 computer.
- Presents.
- Presents!
- What about you, Manuel?
- I want robot!
- Santa loves robots!
(robotic noises)
- Are you guys ready for your presents?
- Yes.
- When you give something
to someone and they feel
touched and warmed and
loved by what you've done,
it is, I think, the embodiment of love.
(holiday music)
- [Keith] Keep on, now, David!
(gasps)
(cheers)
- Oh my gosh.
- One, two, three!
- (gasps) American Girl doll!
- Tablet!
- My computer!
- Monster truck!
- It's a monster truck!
- Meccano!
- You really did know what I want.
- To have something to give
and to be able to experience
the joy of giving, and to
see the people who receive,
there's nothing more magical than that.
- That was the cutest,
sweetest thing of all time.
I've never seen a kid's
face light up like that.
- I just have this bubbling joy feeling.
- I have a huge respect for
all the people out there
who are Santas.
- We're all connected and
that is really what Christmas
is about, what Santa Clause is about,
and what the magic's about.
It's that web between us
all that connects us all.
- Can we get your sister to come up.
- [Samia] She's scared!
- Just caring about
someone else can really
be the difference between
being lonely and being loved.
I think, because you've been,
both been such good girls
to your moms, you both
should have a present.
So, we have a surprise for you, as well.
(gasps)
- It's okay.
- It's, um, I don't know what to say--
- You don't have to say anything.
I think it's great that you
guys are such good girls
for your families.
You are studying and you're
gonna go a lot of great places
in your life, and this is just
to help you along the way.
- [Samia] That's--
- You, even, don't really need this,
but, this is something that you deserve.
For me to be able to give
that to someone, today,
just once, was a, was
really cool. (sniffles)
We did a really good thing. (sniffles)
Merry Christmas, Santa.
- Merry Christmas, Santa.